and uh okay meanwhile in this game we've
seen one move magnus occupying the open
line with his rook and
what
what has eric done there he's just uh
moved his queen he's taken his eye off
the past pawn pass born as a prisoner
must be kept on the locking key and now
you can just advance your pawn blunder
mouth slip yeah blunder
he had 10 seconds he panicked
black's pawn is just going to advance
attacking the white rook and also the
black rook is going to swing down onto
the first row and that's just going to
be the end white's rook forced
it's a prisoner itself now next to the
white king and i think black can just
bring his rook into the game that's
pretty much it yeah once the black rook
comes down to the first rank black
d-pawn is about to become a new queen
and
that just turned around in one move you
were right your anchor it was just a
clock situation and yeah
no that's but that was kind of like the
pattern in day one i mean
eric played really well had great or
promising positions and then just one
horrific blunder and it all turned
around and like you say here it's just a
simple case of the rook will now
move to the bottom row and there's
nothing to stop
black from promoting the queen no maybe
yeah maybe he thought he was going for
some checkmating ideas against the black
king but there's enough defensive pieces
around the black king and the bishop
yeah the black bishop yeah it has uh has
the power to move backwards yeah as well
as forwards
easily missed
yeah and eric that's the thing just he's
self-destructed a few times and it's
just that consistency if he can nail the
time management i think he could be one
of the top grandmasters in the world
he's that talented and okay slightly
surprising by magnus not bringing his
rook down onto the first rank but this
looks good enough the bishop also trying
to support the white the black pawn that
from uh
helping it to promote and there we go
the flat pawn did promote it became a
queen in the process white had to give
up a rook
for bishop and upon and any chances here
to save the game i mean i can see that
already there's a horrible threat in the
air over the rook coming down to give
check and forking the king and queen
so
that's a problem
a pawn
on a5 is going to drop
i wouldn't resign yet though if i were
eric there's still some hope to do with
the white central pawn with the white
d-pawn maybe that would fly forward at
some point maybe you can somehow trick
magnus and get the white queen onto the
same diagonal as the black king and give
some annoying checks but uh where are
you going to put the queen to begin with
so you you've brushed it you've still
got to be very careful
we don't even have to answer eric he
does just give up
it was difficult it was lost but
yeah it was just that one move blunder
and he just gave up hope after that and
you can see his disappointed him